a new low for the biden administration
joe biden is now polling at a whopping
low 38 percent in a new usa today
suffolk poll nearly two-thirds of all
voters do not want joe biden to ever run
for a second term and get this as vice
president kamala harris is polling even
lower her approval rating is a mere 28
percent that's a record record low now
the san francisco chronicle called it
comically bad no vice president in the
history of this country has ever polled
worse ever now a vast majority of
americans are seeing what we have all
known for years joe and kamala are two
deeply incompetent individuals
desperately they want to please their
party's radical socialist base at all
costs every single crisis we now have as
a country is a result of their atrocious
policies
all of them easily prevented all of them
can easily be fixed by simply returning
to the policies that were working of
donald trump now in afghanistan for
example we can go and rescue the people
that joe biden pledged he would never
abandon we can get them home on covid
well biden can follow the lead of
republican governors make monocolonial
i'm sorry monoclonal antibodies
available immediately to anyone that
tests positive of course after approval
from the patient's doctor on inflation
biden can abandon his failed socialist
ideas return to free market capitalism
low taxes less bureaucracy on the issue
of energy which is negatively impacting
all of us but especially poor americans
and middle class americans but on energy
instead of begging opec again and again
and again and getting rejected again and
again joe can immediately return to the
policies that he inherited that is
energy independence the policies that
were working with donald trump now it
would be our in our best national
security interest and every american
will save a fortune on gas we're now at
a seven year high for a gallon of
gasoline we'd save on heating and
cooling our homes and we will pay less
for every single item that we buy at
every store and at the southern border
we can immediately reinstate donald
trump's policies they were all working
you know for example stay in mexico
building the wall ending process and
release said the vice president is just
jetting off to europe to discuss their
migrant crisis during this trip to
france and meanwhile here at home
biden's doj is considering massive
six-figure payouts to certain illegal
immigrants actually rewarding them for
breaking our laws and refusing to
respect our borders and our sovereignty
now there's already preferential
treatment for
people at the border they don't get
covert tested there's no vaccine mandate
and then remember peter ducey last week
asked joe biden about these 450 000
payouts joe biden said at the time it's
garbage and it's not true and it's not
going to happen until joe learned that
the reports were actually true and his
administration was actually implementing
this policy now he's defending defending
it vigorously take a look
reports that we're surfacing that your
administration is planning to pay
illegal immigrants who are separated
from their families at the border up to
450 000 each possibly a million dollars
per family
do you think that that might incentivize
more people to come over illegally if
you guys keep sending that garbage out
yeah but it's not true so this is a
garbage report yeah you said last week
uh that this report about uh migrant
families at the border getting payments
uh with garbage no i didn't say that
yeah
you said everybody coming across the
border gets 500 450 thousand dollars
this number was what you had a problem
for firing dude okay now here's the
thing sure if in fact because of the the
outrageous behavior of the last
administration
you coming across the border whether it
was legal or illegal and you lost your
child
you lost your child it's gone
you deserve some kind of compensation no
matter what the circumstance
first it was garbage not true it's not
going to happen now we get scolded i'm
not sure what's worse joe biden being
completely in the dark about his own
administration's insane policies or then
passionately defending them after
calling them garbage and saying it won't
happen regardless a new massive migrant
caravan is on its way and there is zero
plan to prevent yet another lawless
surge but joe biden thinks we the
american people i guess are too stupid
to realize what's going on in fact over
the weekend joe biden told reporters
americans don't seem to be bright enough
to understand the complexities of the
ongoing supply chain crisis by the way
another self-inflicted crisis by his
policies take a look
people are also worried about you know
coming up and they they don't
understandably why is the price of of of
agricultural products when i go to the
store why is it higher
what like for example if i had if we
were all
going out and having lunch together and
i said let's ask whoever whoever's in
the next table no matter how
what restaurant we're in have haven't
explained the supply chain to us think
they'd understand what we're talking
about
now biden probably should should not be
throwing stones from a cognitive class
house now should he now one of the only
people who probably can comprehend the
supply and chain crisis is the ms nbc
dnc columnist who was mocked online
today for his article that attempted to
sell inflation as a good thing in
reality for most people who don't work
at quote nbc news the supply chain
crisis is not hard to understand first
joe biden paid people not to work he
then forced americans out of the
workforce now with his vaccine mandates
which are now in legal jeopardy and at
the same time he drove up shifting
shipping costs with new regulations and
restrictions on oil and gas and then lo
and behold the supply chain nightmare he
caused the only so-called solution for
the from the biden administration
themselves is learn to live with less
and just suffer in silence and buy your
christmas presents in october now coming
up we're gonna have more on biden's oil
and gas crisis with former energy
secretary rick perry by the way uh we
had some of the lowest prices on gas and
oil and energy under donald trump we
were a net exporter of energy we weren't
importing a single barrel of oil from
saudi arabia or vladimir putin and we
weren't begging opec to produce more oil